and i'm around 26 year olds who say to
me look i'm getting 80 of what i was
making not working so i'm not going to
do anything until this train runs out
if you were to summarize where the
parties are right now the democrats are
the people who are hanging on to the
fading and fumbling institutions and
then republicans have been
overtaken with this anti-institutional
fervor
embodied by donald trump and what i'm
going to suggest is that a lot of us are
not on either of those sides uh the
forward party which i founded now is
trying to call attention to the real
defects and
issues our institutions have in the
hopes that we can rejuvenate them reform
them build new ones
like that's the kind of positive
uh stance that a lot of us wish
existed in our politics as opposed to
the two polls
which are just going to end up
more and more extreme over time yeah but
in addition to that a huge
piece of your platform with the forward
party is this idea of human-centered
capitalism right like the idea that we
need to reconfigure our economy so that
it is not so hyper focused on gdp and
start taking care of the people as
opposed to just making sure that the
economy is churning and using that to
over index on how we're actually doing
as a country
now if you look at the
measurements around such basic things as
infant mortality
quality drinking water access public
education
life expectancy the united states is
28th in the world uh
on those measurements worse for some of
them
uh and that's been declining over the
last number of years one of the cases i
was making when i ran for president is
like look like our quality of life is
sinking into the mud people are getting
increasingly
uh angry and uh distraught and resentful
uh so that's what we should be investing
in and my prescription at the time was
we should give everyone a thousand bucks
a month and
i think that that would help
a great deal
but equally important is for us to focus
on
the right measurements because if you're
an operator
as i am
if you have the wrong measurements
you're going to head in the wrong
direction and right now we're pretending
things are good while people's quality
of life just gets worse and worse so we
should be
centering our sense of progress around
how our kids are doing
our health our mental health our
environmental quality and then if those
things decline then you can look up and
say wow we're really doing poorly as
opposed to right now saying well we must
be doing okay because gdp is up stock
market prices are at record highs
and you know there's a certain subset of
us that are are doing well
in terms of the financial returns other
than ubi which you've spoken about at
length many many times obviously
what are some other ways that we can
address the growing wealth disparity and
this this gap which feels like
the real engine behind the division that
gets played out in the media and in
politics yeah the simplest explanation
for what's going on with our country is
that if you destroy a middle class then
you become subject to all sorts of
terrible
uh impulses and ideas and our middle
class has been getting decimated for
decades starting in the mid 70s around
when i was born actually i was born in
75.
um i spent six years running an
entrepreneurship organization because i
thought the way that we could remedy
this
is to have people starting businesses
and growing businesses all over the
country
and i realized that the scope of my work
was going to be
far too small to try to remedy the the
problem in question
so if you're going to try and rebuild
the middle class it's a massive project
but there are three main things that
make americans sad in terms of their
costs
education health care and housing
each of those has gone up in price much
much more so than incomes for one but
also than the the consumer goods or
media or the things that we consume so
if you were to want to try and make
things better in america you would find
ways to deliver health care more cost
effectively you'd find ways to make
education
less costly and you'd try and keep the
housing prices housing prices and costs
under control
so from the
inception of of this conversation around
ubi that that you helped pioneer and now
is
by dint of the pandemic actually has
been
tested
has your how has your perspective on ubi
evolved or changed since those early
days during the the presidential
campaign
we're living through
now real-time experiments with ubi at
scale um which in in some ways very
exciting
the biggest component is the child tax
credit that has lifted millions of kids
and families out of poverty it's made
people better able to learn it's put
food on the table
442 economists including nobel prize
winners recently signed a letter saying
keep the child tax credit because it's
the best thing we have done
in a long time so that's a component
that i think people are very um excited
about and confident in
the other component around unemployment
relief
has had very very mixed effects in large
part because we've tied the money to not
working and i'm around 26 year olds who
say to me look i'm getting 80 of what i
was making not working so i'm not going
to do anything until this train runs out
a bunch of those people and then only
then will i turn around and start
looking for a job and i look at them and
i say that's entirely reasonable and
rational like you know like who who
would make a different decision so if
we're going to put money into people's
hands we should not be attaching it to
not working um that that's one of the
big lessons that i think people should
take from this time
[Music]
you